ora tutti ragazzi e ben venuto questo
video sono vari generi ed oggi siamo in
un non so neanch'io che cazzo e questo
per i 20 ragazzi sonoro noto ha fornito
perché sono finiti gli esami grazie a
dio è che i ragazzi di oggi si riporta
bomba come abbiamo promesso perché
l'abbiamo già detto prima scala ragazzi
vi avevo promesso che se il montaggio
come di 750 mila iscritti avesse
raggiunto tanto siamo quasi 900mila non
è normale
ho deciso ragazzi di ripartire facendo
non è uno speciale questa ma facendo un
montaggio di tutte le clip che non usate
nello stesso speciale e quindi ragazzi
siccome ormai già parlato un casino
direi che possiamo comincia un ragazzo
sta facendo
no no no profit office of hunt 16 un
testa di minchia è il tocco di classe
praticamente se magari usi la portiere
un po meglio però va bene anche così su
non puoi passare ma sei una stronza
anche adesso per lo vedo faccia di qua
no no
hai visto hunger games bici andrea sta
premiando sta prendendo un tè come
adesso te lo saluto
accoglienza ragazzi di questi tempi è
bellissima che poi senti chi cazzo sei
tu come ha fatto a morire mi vesto donna
cosa cazzo chi la fa entra [ __ ] ma
guarda ma guarda che schifo c4 hai rotto
il cazzo però a el 8 chiaro ma quanto
sei bello da praticamente ragazzi fa
incazzare che alla fine ci arrivi
abbastanza velocemente però ha un po tua
sorella tricheco credetemi se vi dico
che questo è il gioco
credetemi se vicino credetemi seguiti
credetemi se vi dico che questo è il
qualche a troy è perfetto ci siamo
ricchi che l'umore da sottiletta
schiacciato c'è il giornata di merda
io mi farei ammirare con che maestria si
sono fottuti la moto beigua guarda come
se ne va tranquillo cioè quello ci ha
guadagnato una moto così io no io dico
35 senti volta a parte il fatto che ho
trovato una capra e non staccherò la mia
lingua dal suo collo sosta ragazzi aiuto
ma quella è la e la mia lingua o la sua
ragazza dai tratti ma non erano ragazzi
si stanno divertendo 21 si divertono io
andrei avanti solo detto che dove reggia
si 6 stupì l'ho sempre detto che ci sono
persone che perdono la testa per me è
una cosa o che questa era pessima porca
[ __ ] sto ascoltando anche state ma
assisteremo al più bel discorso mai
fatto nella storia pronti via nuovo moto
può poco dopo dai bastardo dai dai vieni
qui vieni detto che devo devo farlo ok
sono finito sotto una macchina perfetta
la piattaforma dopo è una trappola
quindi non ci va come cazzo rimasti
feriti quando si dice che ha un pixel di
saba il culo se sto ca va a cagare
stronza userà il tuo nuovo naso per
rifornirsi di rinnovate energie
io mi sento un deficiente
ma occhio a [ __ ] ma che cazzo ci fai
l'iva fire indietro prima buongiorno
[Musica]
si no no non ci credo quella zona un cio
libero mura tipo di merda sì sì
[Musica]
cazzo di sbarco assalto padre si forma
una canna inchinatevi stronzi al mio
cospetto re capra ragazzi questi sono i
devoti di fa vj tu non mi piace fai
schifo ho visto un tizio nudo io prima e
non è che ma state cucinando qualcosa
col che ciò può guardarlo davanti e lo
spettacolo o forse meglio di no elin
traguardo cazzo non è di pizzi
e superman
[Musica]
il freno amarmi è partito freno a mano
da togliti parti frena fai clic
sì sì sono vivo sono vivo per miracolo
una cosa mi sono fatto malissimo
corrisponde falli ma perché la tua età
non hai la barba perché io in realtà
sono un pesce posso chiamarti amore
magiara subito no troppo facile
sono troppo forte dove cazzo l'ho
spedito quelli in afghanistan
[Applauso]
la madonna che gioca ecco lascia che ti
aiutino mica tutti una testata che
ragazzi un pervertito di merda
vieni richard t6 da che andiamo a
conquistare il mondo vai perfetto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono più che altro a vijay la cassa 4 fa
vigenti
mi scusi sta cercando di parcheggiare i
mamuthones si togliere i [ __ ] che
cazzo qualche già eseguito allora siamo
rimasti una tartaruga tra gli assi
infatti se vedete sono cambiate un caso
ma solo evitando a cazzo
ok siamo vivi per miracolo
se ho trovato le gambe si è chiuso da
solo suo canto non fate commenti
ventaglio e questo sta tornando il pollo
se aspetta non toccare il forno mica
come solo fa
sono sempre comunque meglio di me reagan
ha detto sto facendo adesso e nel
momento più più hot della situazione si
sta toccando freneticamente tratto c'è
un braccio che gli spunta dalle pene non
so perché a caso il suo
ma se io ti pole aiuta sia realtà allora
faccio anch'io
andiamo avanti così è un bacio con la
lingua faccio con le chiappe
non lo so dato che non so che scambio di
sali ma che schifo vinci la bastarda di
merda si sa chi è il numero 1 chiedono
che i muscoli io ci provo ma non
prometto niente io tantissimo ma chi è
quel tizio ragazzi che cazzo fa chi si è
chiusa la porta in faccia non mi stai
seguendo con una mannaia porca [ __ ] è
una cornata pedaci posso provare saia di
nomi far questo non mi far questo
allungarsi ma se i tuoi ghione
[Musica]